Judy Bautista my compadre from the NFL
media group tweeted out again earlier we
want to read that Christmas yeah so this
morning Judy tweeted out I'm told the
number of members of the competition
committee are uncomfortable with the
roughing the passer calls particularly
Clay Matthews and the Vikings game there
is a committee call next week members
are unsure if anything will change this
year all right in my my stellar
colleague from the NFL media group Judy
uppity stat calling in right now
Judy what do you I guess what do you
mean by that let's start out macro here
about that we I think the competition
committee probably is seeing calls made
that they did not anticipate being made
and that they don't want made it's
probably happening much more frequently
than they ever anticipated and they
don't like it especially that the claim
app is one that really started really
kick-started I think the controversy
because that that call changed the
outcome of that game there's no question
about it here's the problem they have a
regularly scheduled call next week the
question is can they change anything or
can they instruct the officials to call
it differently the problem with that is
it's a player safety related issue and
it's tough for the league to walk
anything back thats related to player
safety so they're gonna have to make a
decision about what they can do you know
we saw something similar happen with the
helmet rule in the preseason where it
was called a ton those first few weeks
of the preseason and then they said to
the official you know don't call
incidental contact just you know call
stuff that is more straightforward and
then you saw the number of calls go way
down so the question is can they do
something like that can they you know
can they say to the officials look don't
call anything but the most egregious
situations of a defender landing with
his full weight on the quarterback we'll
see but again it's delicate because it's
a player safety issue yes sure I just
played a couple of sound bites one from
a first-ballot Hall of Fame quarterback
who admitted he is the beneficiary of
rules protecting him in his position and
his is is if you will
advanced age
and longevity in the game is proof maybe
of the rules working drew brees thinking
it's gone too far
Travis Kelce saying that lockstep
everyone in the league thinks it's gone
too far Alex Smith himself said that
clay taught of a Clay Matthews hit that
he took was not appropriate to be
flagged so wouldn't you think that the
league in the competition committee has
wiggle room here to say we've heard you
I I do think there is wiggle room I
agree with you I think there is enough
wiggle room that they can again stay to
the officials call only the most
egregious one where the defender is
clearly landing on purpose on the
quarterback to drive him into the ground
not the kind of thing we saw with Clay
Matthews which is you know a straight
forward sack a tackle but a tackle
exactly the way you wanted not leading
with the helmet but you know it just so
happens that his body you know lands a
little bit on the quarterback I do think
there's enough wiggle room I thing to
keep in mind is the reason they want to
protect quarterbacks so much maybe to
the exclusion of other players
yes it's player safety it's also let's
be honest fans want to watch star
quarterbacks they don't want to see
Aaron Rodgers go out with a shattered
collarbone and miss the rest of the
season they don't want to see injured
quarterbacks they don't want to see
backup quarterbacks they want to see
quarterbacks one thing to keep in mind
scoring went down last year very unusual
in this era of high scoring games
scoring went down that was on the minds
of the league they don't want that to be
a trend um it's important to know that
this was a point of emphasis but landing
with the weight on the quarterback rule
has been on the books since the 90s this
has just made a point of emphasis this
year and the reason it's a point of
emphasis is because at the end of each
season the league sends out a
questionnaire to its teams and says what
do you think we ought to be looking at
and one of the things that came back as
what teams wanted them to look at was
weight landing on the quarterback that
was because of what happened to Aaron
Rodgers last year when a defender landed
on him drove him into the ground and the
collarbone broken Aaron Rodgers was gone
so that's why they took a look at it
that's why they made it a points point
of emphasis this year it's all joined in
it's all knitted together it'll be
interesting to see what they
come up with next week or you know
there's a league meeting in October if
they revisit the rule then but again
it's a it's a tough balancing act
I assume Roger Goodell will have some
say in what the outcome is yeah so last
one for you Judy is is the the league is
willing to wait till next week's call I
mean they're willing to go through
another week where we're a call like
this might affect a win-loss like it did
in week two between the Vikings and the
Packers or in the case of William Hayes
I've got Adam GaSe on tomorrow show
where a player gets hurt trying to avoid
putting body weight on a quarterback it
certainly seems of this moment that they
are willing to wait for next week don't
forget there's also internal
communication among the officials with
the officiating office so they can do
something informal
without making it a formal public
statement and and you know I'm sure
those conversations go on constantly but
as of right now this afternoon it seems
like they are willing to wait but look
it's early in an NFL week Tuesday
afternoon early in an NFL week so
certainly stuff can happen between now
and Sunday Judy thanks for the call
we'll chat soon my pleasure
that's Judy Batista of the NFL Network
NFL Media Group the Rich Eisen show
weekdays at noon eastern on audience